monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur nos
forces de sécurité intérieures sont dans
un état général très inquiétant pas un
jour ne se passe sans que nos policiers
et nos gendarmes ne soit caillasser
insulter molesté leur agression se
comptent par centaines
leur moral est on ne peut plus bas ils
ne se sentent pas soutenus peut
considérer mal équipés la vague de
suicides se poursuit et s'amplifie
puisque puis jusque dans des lieux
hautement symbolique comme un appel au
secours
le projet de loi de finances ne répond
pas à leurs espoirs à leurs attentes
il ne fait qu'entretenir une situation
qui les a amenés là où ils sont
pourtant la violence ne cesse
d'augmenter dans les villes et les
campagnes
elle devient habituel voix en permanente
l'insécurité gagne sans cesse du terrain
l'émission de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure se multiplient constamment la
réponse pénale n'est pas en adéquation
avec cette nouvelle forme de criminalité
au sénat avec la commission d' enquête
sur l'état des forces de sécurité
intérieure nous avons travaillé pendant
plus de six mois
mené près d'une centaine d'auditions
effectué de nombreux déplacements sur le
terrain et rédigé 35 propositions
concrètes qui sont le reflet des
attentes de ces hommes et de ces femmes
qui nous protègent les gendarmes et les
policiers attendent des réponses
concrètes
il en va de leur sécurité de celles de
nos concitoyens monsieur le ministre ma
question est simple dans votre plan
d'action quels moyens comptez-vous
donner aux forces de sécurité intérieure
pour stopper ce climat de violence qui
s'accentue de jour en jour merci merci
la parole à monsieur christophe castaner
ministre de l'intérieur pour dix minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs c'est un terme sur le sénateur
leroy
vous avez raison dans le constat
d'inquiétude d'inquiétude et de non
respect mais je crois qu'on est tous
d'accord donc c'est pas la peine qu'on
réagisse nous sommes tous d'accord qu'il
ya aujourd'hui un non respect un au
respect des institutions et dont ce non
respect des institutions une mise en
cause presque systématique dans certains
quartiers de nos forces de sécurité
et chaque fois que l'on met en cause une
force et qu on était un policier un
gendarme c'est la république que l'on
met en cause et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut apporter tout notre
soutien chaque jour presque
je rencontre des policiers jean contre
des gendarmes chants contes nos forces
de sécurité pour justement être à leurs
côtés mais il faut effectivement
traduire cela en deux ans le budget du
ministère de l'intérieur aura augmenté
de plus de 1 milliard dans quelques
jours je viendrai devant vous présenter
un budget qui augmente de 3 5%
est-ce que ça suffit pour régler tous
les problèmes la réponse est non mais
nous en sommes convaincus mais c'est
déjà une augmentation de 3 5% c'est une
augmentation de 575 millions d'euros
et je sais que j'aurai votre soutien
n'ont pas forcément sur toutes les
politiques mais sur la volonté de
réarmer de réarmer nos forces de
sécurité parce que c'est nécessaire par
un plan d'action majeure dans
l'immobilier par un plan d'action
majeure dans le recrutement et dans
l'équipement de nos forces de l'ordre de
1500 personnes seront recrutées l'année
prochaine et nous allons ouvrir rien que
pour la police près de 4500 postes dans
nos écoles de formation parce qu'il faut
bien évidemment remplacé aussi les
départs à la retraite et nous le ferons
nous avons poussé au maximum les
capacités de notre formation pour garder
un système suffisamment sélectif et nous
aurons les moyens de faire cela et 2500
postes seront ouverts en plus des 2000
postes ouverts cette année
et cet effort sera poursuivi l'année
suivante parce que sur le quinquennat
nous voulons recruter dix mille
policiers et gendarmes supplémentaires
et très vite et l'effort a été porté sur
les premières années les dernières
années il n'y aura besoin de plus que de
recruter 1500 personnes par an parce que
justement l'effort est porté
immédiatement mais il nous faut aussi
travailler sur la question de
l'équipement et sur la défense et je
vais vous dire que nous devons nous
retrouver sur la revendication sur
l'exigence que jamais aucun incident
aucune mise en cause aucune violence
contre les forces de sécurité gendarmes
policiers pompiers
et ne soient acceptables dans ce pays et
je sais pouvoir compter sur vous merci
vous ai écoutés mais n'oubliez pas
d'entendre votre prédécesseur qui disait
aujourd'hui les français sont côte à
côte
demain ils seront face à face ne se met
pas la faiblesse vous récolterez la
violence
[Applaudissements]